bonjour françois poule et mathias merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors on connaît désormais la liste des
15 pays dont les ressortissants sont
autorisés à voyager dans l'union
européenne faut-il craindre avec cette
réouverture des frontières alors que
certains pays reconfirme localement je
crois que la tâche des dirigeants
l'union européenne était très difficile
parce qu'il fallait faire la part des
choses d'une part essayer de trouver une
solution à la proche de la saison
touristique qui est très importante pour
ces pays européens et d'autre part ne
pas menacer comme vous venez de le dire
une résurgence du virus pour cela donc
l'europe finalement s'est ressoudé une
certaine manière puisque elle a réussi à
retrouver une certaine cohérence dans
une position commune des 27 et même en
incluant une certaine manière le royaume
uni qui est encore dans l'union
européenne une certaine convergence pour
déterminer quels sont les pays pour
lesquels on ne pouvait pas autoriser une
retour vers l'europe en particulier des
grands pays comme les etats-unis comme
la russie comme le brésil ou la turquie
ce sont des pays qui pèse lourd il faut
le comprendre dans l'économie européenne
dans la mesure où certains pays comme la
grèce par exemple le tourisme représente
plus de 20% du pib
d'autres pays comme la france l'italie
ou l'espagne
c'est près de 10% du pib donc l'absence
de touristes russes en ce qui concerne
par exemple l'allemagne et la grèce ou
américaines ce qui concerne l'italie ni
la france en particulier va peser m'a
pesé lourd sur le plan économique cela
peut peser jusqu'à plus de 1 milliard
d'euros de pertes
donc c'était une décision importante
mais c'est une décision qui permet à
l'europe finalement de redonner une
certaine forme de cohérence à son action
une chorale cohérence qu'elle n'avait pu
trouver jusqu'à maintenant
justement vous venez de
dire le secteur art et aériens mais
aussi le secteur du tourisme a
lourdement été frappés par ces crises
sanitaires
est ce qu'elle peut permettre justement
c'est trop ouverture de relancer
l'économie bien que la saison estivale
était courte et au final alors je ne
dirais pas forcément la relancer mais au
moins de la sauver de la sauver d'une
catastrophe qui était une catastrophe
annoncée je pense que l'europe a profité
d'une situation sanitaire qui lui était
plutôt favorable puisqu'il faut bien
reconnaître qu'actuellement la plupart
des pays d'europe sont en période de
déconfinement et non pas de confinement
alors que le rêve mais cela dit encore
il ya quelques jours la situation semble
s'aggraver dans la plupart des pays du
monde
or face à cela effectivement il fallait
trouver la juste mesure
ses débuts ont été difficiles mais quel
est le critère en fait ce critère c'est
de faire en sorte que les pays pour
lesquels la situation du virus s'aggrave
et bien que ces pays là ne pourrait pas
finalement bénéficié d'un retour vers
l'europe
et puis il fallait aussi faire en sorte
que finalement dans les pays où la
situation tangue encore grave mais tend
à s'améliorer que cela puisse
éventuellement sous conditions
effectivement pas avoir accès à l'europe
tout en respectant une règle de
réciprocité puisque par exemple des pays
comme la chine on est prêt
éventuellement accepter des touristes
chinois condition que la chine elle
accepte des touristes européens l'europe
justement sera au centre des
préoccupations dans gala merkel puisque
l'allemagne a pris aujourd'hui la
présidence de l'union pour six mois que
peut-on justement espérer de cette
présidence allemande mais je crois que
me l'avait dit jean-marc sylvestre peu
de temps avant moi je crois que l'europe
attend beaucoup finalement d'une relance
une relance qui est d'autant plus
nécessaire parce que après ces crises de
gros navires us il va bien falloir
relancer les économies mais les relancer
ensemble et non pas séparément et c'est
le grand atout de l'allemagne qui pour
la première fois accepté même lit
d'une mutualisation de la dette et bien
c'est une occasion pour angela merkel
qui je signale à ce propos a retrouvé un
petit peu tout sont russes de leaders
politiques européens
c'est une occasion pour angela merkel de
ressouder le continent qui était un peu
partir en ordre dispersé donc la
présidence allemande
ce n'est pas rien et c'est aussi pour
angela merkel l'occasion de montrer
qu'elle n'est pas encore complètement
sortis du de l'univers politique
merci beaucoup françois paul et mathis
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste de l'europe